The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to review a
little bit the things we did
last time, and carry them
just a little bit
further, in some cases.
Remember, we're talking about
the Markov processes now.
We defined a countable state
Markov process in terms of an
embedded Markov chain
and in each state an
embedded Markov chain.
There's a parameter nu sub i,
which is the rate of an
exponential process for
leaving that state.
And that describes what the
Markov process does because
knowing what the Markov chain
does and knowing what these
exponential random variables do
that gives you everything
you need, if you will, to
simulate this process.
It gives you, in principle,
everything you need to
calculate everything you want to
know about what's going on
in the process.
So if you remember, we
found out that the--
we essentially defined steady
state probabilities for the
process in terms of the steady
Markov chain.
And what we were doing there
is to first, restrict
ourselves to the case where the
Markov chain is positive--
well, at least, is recurrent.
But let's imagine this positive
recurrence so we
don't have to worry about those
distinctions for the
time being.
If it's positive recurrent
there's a set of pi sub j,
which gives the steady state
probability that a transition,
over the long term, is going
to go into state j.
If you look at the process
overall time, if you look at a
sample path of it, with
probability one pi sub j, is a
fraction of transitions
that go into state j.
Since when you're in state j,
the expected amount of time
that you stay in state
j is 1 over nu sub j.
Nu sub j is the rate of an
exponential random variable so
the expected value of that
random variable is 1 over nu
sub j, so the fraction of time
that you should be in state j
should be proportional to
pi j over nu sub j.
But since these fractions have
to add up to 1, we normalize
it by dividing by the
sum of pi k over--
pi sub k over nu sub k.
That's the formula
that we into it.
We showed last time that this
formula made sense.
What we showed is that
if you look at the--
What's that peculiar
thing doing there?
If you look at the rate at
which transitions are
occurring in this Markov chain,
which is determined by
everything going on, but this
rate at which transitions are
occurring, assuming we start in
state i is equal to 1 over
the sum over k of pi sub
k over nu sub k.
Namely, it's the same
denominator over here, and you
can interpret this in the same
way as you interpret this.
This is independent of the
state that you start in.
These probabilities here, these
fractions of time in
each state, are independent
of where you start.
So Mi of t is a sample path,
average rate at which
transitions occur with
probability 1.
Namely, no matter where you
start, and no matter what
sample path you're looking at
with probability one, what you
wind up with is a number of
transitions up to time t
divided by t, which goes to a
limit of probability one, and
it's independent of the
starting state.
OK, so if this sum here is
infinite then something
peculiar is happening because
when this sum is infinite,
even though the pi sub j's are
positive, even though the
embedded Markov chain is
positive recurrent, these
fractions of time in
each state don't
make any sense anymore.
So that in fact, what you have
is a Markov process which is
getting slower and slower
and slower.
That's what this equals
infinity means.
It means that these pi sub k's,
the probability of being
in certain states
with very high--
If the probability is being high
of states where you spend
a long time in those states
and that sum adds up to
infinity, this transition
rate is equal to zero.
It means that the transitions
rates are getting slower and
slower and slower, we showed an
example of that of an mm1q.
Well, it wasn't quite mm1, but
it was like an mm1q, but it
had the property that as you
moved up to higher and higher
states, both arrivals got slower
and slower, and also
the service time got
slower and slower.
We called this a rattled
server, and
also discouraged arrival.
So with the two of those things,
as you move up to
higher and higher states, what
happens is transitions get
slower and slower and
eventually, you settle down in
a situation where nothing
is getting done.
And that's because
of the sum here.
It's not because of anything
peculiar in
any one given state.
Let's see, where we're we?
OK, if this is equal to
infinity, the transition rate
goes to 0 and the process has
no meaningful steady state.
Otherwise, the steady
state uniquely
satisfies this equation.
That's what we showed
less time.
This says that the rate in
equals the rate out for each
state, that's what this
equation says.
This quantity over here p sub
j is the probability that
you're in state j, at any
given time, nu sub j is
expected amount of time
you stay in there.
So this is the, in a sense, this
product here corresponds
to the rate in state j.
The sum over here corresponds
to the rate at which you're
going into state j.
All of these P's are greater
than 0, and the sum of the P's
are equal to 1.
This is the case though we
normally call a positive
recurrent process.
I notice I didn't define
that in the notes.
I now notice, thinking about
it even more, that I'm not
sure I want to define it that
way, but anyway that's what
it's usually called.
It's called a positive
recurrent process.
It requires both that this is
less than infinity and the
steady state probabilities
pi sub j have a solution.
If you have a birth/death
process, you can deal with the
birth/death process in exactly
the same way as we dealt with
birth/death Markov chains.
Namely, what goes up must
eventually come down.
And what that means is a P sub
j, this is the fraction of
time you're in state j.
This is the rate at which you
move up, so this combination
here is the overall rate at
which you're moving up, not
conditional on being
in state j.
This is the overall probability
of moving down.
So the transition rate up, in
any given state, equals the
transition rate down.
OK, so that's a useful
equation.
That's the way you
usually solve
for birth/death processes.
The same as you use for solving
for change, you can
get it from the chain equation
very easily.
If you have an irreducible
process, an irreducible
process is one where every state
communicates with every
other state, remember?
Same as the definition
for change.
If there is a solution to these
equations here, mainly,
these are the equations where
you directly solved for the
average time in each state.
The time spent in blah,
blah, blah--
What this is saying again, is
the rate at which you leave
state j is what this is, is
equal to the rate at which you
enter state j, which
is what this is.
So this again, is saying what
comes in must go out.
And if this equation is
satisfied, then the embedded
chain is positive recurrent and
instead of solving for the
P's from the pi's, you're
solving for the pi's from the
P. It's the same kind
of equation.
Notice before P sub j was equal
to pi sub j over nu sub
j normalized.
Now, pi sub j is equal
to a P sub j, nu sub
j normalized again.
And you normalize this because
the rate at which transitions
are taking place is
normally not 1.
We also found that this rate
at which transitions are
taking place, 1 over this
quantity, is also equal to
this sum here.
So the sum of Pj nu sub j is
the overall rate at which
transitions are taking place.
Now, if the sum of nu i times
p sub i is infinite then,
according to this formula, each
pi sub j is equal to 0,
which says that the embedded
Markov chain has to be either
transient or is null-recurrent,
and something
very, very strange
is going on.
Because here we've solved these
equations, we found
positive P sub j's, positive
probabilities of being in each
state or, at least, that's the
way we try to interpret it.
And then we find that as far
as the transition rates are
concerned all of the
transition rates
are equal to 0.
So what's going on?
I must admit frankly, I don't
know what's going on.
Because, I mean, I know
mathematically
what's going on.
This is what the
equations say.
There's a nice example of it,
which I'll look at in the next
slide, but to interpret this in
any very satisfactory way
seems to be very hard.
OK, here's the example, and
we talked about this a
little bit last time.
If we look at the embedded
chain, we can call this a
hyperactive birth/death chain.
It's hyperactive in the sense
that the higher the state gets
the faster the thing runs.
So as you get more customers
into this queue, you could
imagine then the server
runs faster, the
customers arrive faster.
And as it builds up, this keeps
on going faster and
faster and faster.
For this chain, it looks like
it's stable, doesn't it?
Because the probability
of going up--
No, it looks like
it's not stable.
The probability of
going up is 0.6.
The probability of going
down this 0.4.
We have that in each state.
This is what we've seen often
for mm1q's, where things come
in at a faster rate than they
go out, and the only thing
that could happen is the
queue builds up.
Namely, you start out down here,
and you keep moving up
and you move up forever, so
something bazaar is happening.
But then, we solve these
equations for the steady state
fraction of time we spend
in each state,
and what do we get?
Because this is the probability
of going up, and
this is the probability of
going down from state 1.
And the rate at which things
happen from state 1 is 2.
happen in state 2 is 4,
what's going on?
Since the rate at which things
happen here is 4, this rate of
going down is 2 times 1.6.
Here we are in--
If we're in state 1 and moving
up, the rate at which
transitions occur
in state 1 is 2.
The probability that the
transition is up is 0.6, so
the rate of an upper
transition is
0.6 times 2, 1.2.
If we're in this state, higher
rate of transitions there
twice as high, you're moving
down with probability 0.4, but
since the rate is twice as
high, the overall rate at
which things are going
down is 1.6.
This looks like a stable mm1q.
OK, bizarre.
We can solve this.
We can solve this with the
formula for solving for the
average time in each state.
And what do we get using p sub
j times q sub j, j plus 1. p
sub j is the fraction
of time in state j.
q sub j, j plus 1, is
the rate at which we
move out of that state.
That's equal to the fraction of
time or in state j plus 1
times the rate at which we're
moving down from j plus 1 to
j, if these equations
make any sense.
But at any rate, we can solve
these equations p sub j plus 1
has to equal 3/4 p sub j.
That ratio there is 3/4.
And the average time in each
state, according to these
equations, which we can see
there's something funny about
it, but it's 1/4 times 3/4
to the j because of this
relationship here.
But the sum of p sub j times nu
sub j is equal to infinity,
which is why we can't get any
steady state embedded chain
probabilities.
OK, well, in an effort to
understand this, what you can
do is you can truncate
this as mm1 Markov
process to just k states.
And it's very easy to truncate
the Markov process because all
you have to do is just cut off
all the transition rates that
go into these higher
rate states.
When you cut off everything
going beyond here, what you
get is just this Markov
process shown here.
Well, Markov chain shown here,
Markov process shown here,
and, at this point, we have
a finite number of states.
Nothing funny can happen.
And what we get if we actually
go through all the
calculations is that the
fraction of time in state j is
1/4 times 1 minus
3/4 to the k.
This term goes to 0 with k,
so this whole term here is
unimportant.
Times 3/4 to the j.
This 1/4 times 3/4 to the j
was the result we had here
when we looked at all
the states there.
Pi sub j, looking at this
chain here, which is an
unstable chain, you
go up with higher
probability than you go down.
What you get is pi sub j is 1/3
times 1 minus 2/3 to the
k, this term is going to 0
as k increases, times 2/3
to the k minus j.
In other words, when you
truncate this change here,
which is unstable, what's going
to happen is that you're
going to tend to stay in
the higher states.
And you're going to dribble down
to the lower states with
very little probability
in the lower states.
As you increase k and increase
the number of states that
you're dealing with what's
happening is that you're
increasingly spending most of
your time and these higher
ordered states.
So as you increase k, you just
move up one on which states
are most likely.
So you get this kind of result
here 2/3 to the k minus j,
which is decreasing
rapidly with k.
Which says, as k goes to
infinity, this goes to 0 for
all j, and this goes to a
sensible quantity for each j.
When you sum up p sub j times
nu sub j, this is giving you
the rate at which transitions
occur, what you get is this
term, which doesn't amount to
anything times 1/2 times 3/2
to the k minus 1.
This term here is approaching
infinity exponentially, which
says that something doesn't
make any sense here.
What's happening in this queue
is that the rate at which
transitions occur is
going to infinity.
If you start out at state
0, very rapidly the
state builds up.
The higher the state
goes up, the faster
the transitions become.
So the transition rate is
approaching infinity, and this
solution here, which looks like
it makes perfect sense,
doesn't make any sense at all.
Because in fact, what's
happening is the transition
rate is increasing as time goes
on, whether the number of
transitions in a finite time
is infinite are not with
probability 1.
I don't know.
I can't figure out how to
solve that problem.
If I figure out how to do
it, I will let you know.
But anyway, the point is, for
this embedded chain in this
same process, the idea of
steady state is totally
meaningless.
So the caution there is as you
deal with Markov processes
more and more, and any time you
deal with killing a great
deal, you deal with this kind
of process all the time.
What you normally do then is
you start solving for these
probabilities.
You simulate something, you
figure out what these
probabilities are from the
simulation, everything looks
fine until you look at
the embedded chain.
And then when you look at the
embedded chain, you realize
that this is all nonsense.
I wish I could say more about
this but I can't.
But anyway, it's a note of
caution when you're dealing
with Markov processes.
Check what the embedded chain is
doing because it might not
be doing something very nice.
Let's go onto reversibility
for Markov processes.
We talked about reversibility
for Markov chains, sort of
half understood what
was going on there.
Fortunately, for Markov
processes, I think it's a
little easier to see what's
going on than it was for
Markov chains.
So if you almost understand
reversibility for Markov
chains then I'll be easy
to get the extra things
that you need here.
For any Markov chain in steady
state, the backward transition
probabilities were defined as
pi sub i times Pi(j) star is
equal to pi j times
P(j)i star.
In other words, the transition
from i to j, the probability
of being in state i and going
to state j, which is this
expression right here.
You can write it in two
different ways.
And there's nothing magical
or sophisticated here.
It's the probability that Xn
plus 1 is equal to i times the
probability that Xn is equal
to j, given that the next
state is equal to i.
We can do that.
There's nothing wrong with
talking about the probability
that the state now as j, given
that the state one time from
now, the state i.
And that's also equal to the
probability that Xn is equal
to j times the probability.
You go from j to i.
This is just base law written in
a particularly simple form.
This also holds for the embed
chain of a Markov process.
So to draw a picture for this,
you're sitting here in state
i, eventually, at some time
t1, there's a transition.
You go to state j.
In state j, there's a transition
rate nu sub j, so
after some time, whose expected
value is 1 over nu
sub j at time t2, you
go to another state.
That new state say is state k,
so you start out in state i,
you go to state j, you stick
there for a time, nu sub j,
and then you go on to state k.
OK, so if we look at this
picture again, and we look at
it in terms of the sample time
Markov chain, what's going on?
If you're moving right,
in other words,
moving up in time.
And I again, urge you if you
have trouble thinking of time
running backwards, think of left
and right, because you
will have no trouble thinking
of things going to the left
and things going to the right.
So moving to the right, which
is the normal way to move
after entering state j, the
exit rate is nu sub j.
In other words, we exit in each
delta with a probability
nu sub j times delta.
The same holds moving left.
In other words, if you're at
time t2, if moving this way
you move into state
j, what happens?
You leave state j going leftward
in each delta unit
time with--
There's this same rate here,
which is the rate when you
look at it either way, is this
rate here at which you leave
this state j, which is delta nu
sub j, and all we're using
here is the memorylessness of
the exponential distribution.
That's the only thing
going on here.
So Poisson process is clearly
reversible from the
incremental definition, and
that's what we're using here.
And that what this means is
that the steady state
probabilities, the pi sub i's,
and also, the nu sub i's,
which are the rates at which
transitions occur, are the
same going left as
going right.
So this is the same kind of
thing we had before, but I
think now, you can see it more
easily because there's a
finite amount of time that
you're sticking in state j,
and it's a random
amount of time.
And moving in one direction,
you're moving out of state j
with this constant rate delta,
delta times nu j.
When you're going the other way,
it's the same probability
that you're going out, going
backwards in time, over a
period delta of delta
times nu sub j.
It's the same both ways.
And I think this is easier
to see than the
thing we did before.
OK, so the probability of having
a right transition from
j to k in a little period of
time as p sub j, fraction of
time in state j, times
q sub jk transition
rating k times delta.
Similarly, if q star sub kj
is the left going process
transition rate, the probability
of having the same
transition as pk times
q star sub kj, thus
we have this equation.
And this equation,
turns into this.
The rate going backwards is
going from k to j is equal to
nu sub k times the rate for
the embedding Markov chain
going backwards.
So we define a Markov process as
being reversible if q sub i
j star, if the backward rate is
equal to the forward rate
for all i and j.
And if we assume positive
recurrence and we assume that
pi sub i over nu sub i is less
than infinity, which is the
stability equation, which says
that the rate of transitions
has to be finite, then the
Markov process is reversible,
if and only if, the
embedded chain is.
OK, so this gives you a nice
easy condition to talk about
reversibility.
You can either show that the
chain is reversible or the
process is reversible.
They both work the same way.
And if you understand chains
then you can use that to
understand processes.
If you understand processes,
you can use that
to understand chains.
OK, so from that we get
what I like to call
the guessing theorem.
Suppose a Markov process is
irreducible, this means every
state communicates with every
other state, it's easy to
verify irreducibility.
It's sometimes hard to verify
whether a chain is positive
recurrent or not and whether
the process is positive
recurrent or not.
So this guessing theorem says
if a Markov process is
irreducible and if p sub i is
a set of probabilities that
satisfy this equation here--
these are the reversibility
equations--
p sub i times qij, rate at which
you're going up is equal
to the rate at which you're
going down for all i and j.
And when you find that p sub i
that satisfies these equations
here, if it also satisfies this
equation, then, in fact,
you're in business.
And what the theorem says is
first, all of these average
probabilities are greater than
zero for all i, 2, these
average probabilities, this p
sub i, is the sample-path
fraction of time in state 1
with probability 1, 3, the
process is reversible,
and 4, the embedded
chain is positive recurrent.
You get, all at once--
all you've got to
do is find the
solution to those equations.
If you can find the solution
to those equations and it
satisfies this, then
you're done.
You don't need a birth/death
chain or anything else.
All you need to do is guess a
solution to those equations.
If you get one, then
that establishes
everything you need.
OK, useful application.
All birth/death processes which
satisfy this finite
number of transition conditions
are reversible.
Remember, we talked about trees
with the Markov condition.
If you have a Markov graph
which is a tree, and it
satisfies this condition, then
that process has to be
reversible.
You get it from this theorem
also because, again, you have
this condition that what goes
over a branch in a tree, you
can only go up on that
branch one more time,
then you can go down.
So you've got the same equality
and the argument is
exactly the same.
OK.
So what do we get out of this?
What we get is Burke's
theorem.
And what this Burke's
theorem says--
Burke's theorem here, for
processes, is what you usually
think of as Burke's theorem.
It was the original statement
of Burke's Theorem before
people started to look at
sample time chains.
And what it says is, given an
M/M/1 queue in steady-state
with arrival rate lambda
less than mu--
if you look at that condition,
that's exactly what you need
for the stability condition
we've been talking about--
the departure process is Poisson
with rate lambda.
Now you would think
the process--
and when we're thinking about
Markov chains, you all thought
when you saw this that the
departure process had rate mu
because the server was operating
at rate and mu, who
said no, that's not right.
Because the service rate is mu
anytime the server is active.
But is lambda is less
than mu the server
is not always active.
The server is sometimes idle and
therefore, what comes in
is the same as what goes out.
The only possibility is that
this queue is gradually
building up over time, and then
what goes out is less
than what comes in.
But otherwise, what comes
in is what goes out.
And the rate at which the server
is working is not mu,
that the server is working
a rate lambda.
Mainly, the server is working at
rate mu when it has things
to do but every time it doesn't
have things to do it
takes a coffee break.
It's not doing anything.
And at that point, when you
amortized over the time the
server is taking coffee breaks
and the time the server is
working the rate is lambda
because that's the rate at
which things are coming in.
You can only get one thing
out for each thing in.
So either the queue builds up
forever, in which case, what's
going out is less than what's
coming in or the queue is not
building up and what goes out
is exactly what's coming in.
I hope looking at it that way
convinces you that what's
coming out here is the same
rate as what's going in.
OK, the next thing is that the
state x of t is independent of
the departures before t.
This was the same as the
condition we had when we were
looking at Markov chains.
The state x of t is
independent of the
departure before t.
Whether you look at this thing
forward or backward, the state
is just the height of
that graph there.
So when you're looking at it
backwards, the state that you
go through over the process is
the same as the set of states
when you're looking at
it the other way.
It's just that you have
to flip it around.
And it says that the state
is independent of
departures before t.
The reason for that is that when
you look at the backward
process, every departure here
is an arrival here.
These arrivals here--
This is an arrival, this
is an arrival,
this is a third arrival.
This is the fourth arrival
and those depart later.
When you're looking at it that
way, what's going on?
These things that are called
departures up in the top graph
are called arrivals when you're
looking at it going
this way like.
What this is saying is-- when
you're looking at this as an
M/M/1 process, what it's saying
is for the backward
M/M/1 process, the arrivals that
come in later than me do
not affect my service time.
This is because we have first
come first serve service, and
if somebody with an
enormous service
requirement comes after me--
If I'm at the supermarket and
somebody comes in with three
big barrels of food, I breath
a sigh of relief because I'm
there first.
And I get out quickly,
and I don't have to
wait for this person.
And that's essentially,
what this is saying.
OK, the third one for first come
first serve service, a
customer's arrival time, given
that it departs at time t, is
independent of the departures
before time t.
That's almost the same
as two, but it's not
quite the same as two.
It only applies if
you have first
come first serve service.
This is not quite true
for Markov chains.
You remember when we
stated Burke's
theorem for Markov chains.
We only had these first two
statements, and now we have
this third statement.
Let me try to explain in the
next slide why that's true.
If I can explain this to you and
make you believe it on the
first time I feel very
proud of myself.
Because this is the kind of
thing you have to have
explained to you three times.
You have to sit down
and think about it.
The first three times you
think about it, you say,
that's all baloney.
The fourth time you
think about it,
you say, that's false.
And maybe the fifth time you
say, it's false again.
And the sixth time you look at
it just the right way, and it
turns out to be true.
And then you go back a week
later, and it's false again.
But anyway, let me try.
We're going to first look
at the right moving
sample path, OK?
So departure at t up here is
an arrival [? in ?] the
departure in the right moving
sample path is an arrival in
the M/M/1 left moving
sample path.
For first come first
service, looking at
the left moving process--
that's the left moving
process--
the departure time of an
arrival at time t--
here's an arrival at time t--
the departure of that arrival,
in this case, is that
departure right there.
That departure time depends on
the arrivals and the service
requirements back over here
because when we're looking at
things going this way, this
is what happens first.
This is what happens later.
So we have these arrivals
coming in this way, this
arrival here has
nothing to do--
Well, this arrival here, in
general, does have something
to do with this arrival, because
if this arrival were
not finished by this time, we
would have to wait for it.
The waiting time of this arrival
here depends on what
happened before, which
is over here.
It does not depend on the
arrivals after it because it's
first come first
serve service.
And therefore, anything
that comes after is
sitting behind us.
It doesn't bother us at all.
OK, for the corresponding right
moving process then
coming back the other way, the
arrival time of that departure
is independent as the departures
before t, and
that's exactly what this
theorem is saying.
In order to make sense of this
you have to do something that
we've been doing all along.
We don't always talk about is
very much, but I hope you're
getting used to doing it.
You talk about sample paths.
When you're talking about sample
paths, you're talking
about one particular
instantiation of the process.
You prove a result for that
sample path, then you say,
that's true for all
sample paths.
And then, you say, a ha, then it
must be true for the random
variables of which these sample
paths are sample cases.
That's an argument we go
through so many times.
In fact, when you take
probability the first time,
pretty soon it becomes second
nature to you, and
every once in while--
In fact it becomes so much
second nature, that most
people don't even distinguish
between random variables and
actual sample path numbers.
They use the same symbol
for both of them.
Every once in a while I get
confused by this, but
eventually, they get it
straightened out, and that's
part of what this argument
is here.
OK, let's test our understanding
now.
Let's look at tandem
M/M/1 queues.
First, we don't quite know what
that means, but let's
consider two queues, one sitting
right after the other.
Departures from the first queue
move directly into the
second queue.
The partition here moved
directly into here.
I've shown these departures at
rate lambda because what
Burke's theorem says, is that
these departures are, in fact,
a Poisson process,
we rate lambda.
You think you're through at this
point, but you're not.
You still have some difficult
thinking to go through.
So you're assuming originally,
that the input is Poisson.
You're assuming that the first
queue has exponential
services, the service times are
independent of each other,
they're all iid, and they're
independent of the
inter-arrival times.
So this first thing here is
just an M/M/1 queue like
you're used to.
We now know that what's coming
out of that first queue is a
Poisson process.
It's a little hard to
look at as a Poisson
process but it is.
It is not a Poisson process if
you're conditioning on what's
going on in the first queue.
It's not a Poisson process
conditional on these arrival
times here or on these
service times here.
It's only a Poisson process if
we're looking at the departure
times unconditional
on anything else.
Conditional only on the other
departure times or iid, That's
what we've proven.
But conditional on what's going
on in the first queues
of those departures, are
sure as hell not even
close to doing iid.
I mean, if you've got a lot of
arrivals and you've got a lot
of long service times, the queue
is going to get busy.
And what's coming out of that
queue is going to be at rate
mu, which is what all of you
believe until you see this
theorem, and think it through.
And that's why you believe it,
because you look normally, at
time moving from
left to right.
We're going to assume the
service time at rates mu 1 and
mu 2 are independent from
queue to queue.
And they're independent--
Ah, I didn't change that.
This doesn't make any sense.
The service rates at mu1 and mu2
are independent from this
queue to this queue, and they're
independent of the
inter-arrival times
back there.
Now, why do I have
to change that?
Why can't I say that the service
times at mu1 and mu2
are independent of both the
arrivals to the first queue
and the arrivals to
the second queue?
Because first, I can't assume
things that are not given by
the model of the problem.
The things going from queue 1
into queue 2, I know they're
Poisson now, but I don't know
that they're Poisson
independent of what's going
into the first queue, and
independent of the service times
in the first queue, and
they certainly aren't.
So what I have to say here is
they're independent from queue
to queue and independent
of the arrivals
at the first queue.
OK, we know that the arrivals
at queue 2 are
Poisson at rate lambda.
That's true by Burke's
theorem.
And they're independent of
the service times at 2.
That alone makes the
second queue M/M/1.
Because the second queue
has arrivals.
It has service times.
The arrivals are independent
of the service times.
It is, by definition, what
an M/M/1 queue is.
It might depend on what's going
on in the first queue to
a certain extent.
Burke's theorem tells us, in one
sense, it doesn't depend
on it, and that's the next thing
we have to deal with.
The states of the two systems
are independent and the time
of a customer in system
one is independent of
that in state two.
I'm not going to try to convince
you of that here.
The text does, I think, do
a pretty good job of
convincing you of it.
It's a more complicated
argument than this.
And s something which you just
have to either say, I believe
it because I'm too tired
to do anything else.
Or you have to go through it
several times, sometimes
disbelieving and sometimes
believing until finally,
saying, I guess it
must be true.
OK, so enough of that.
Let's go on to random walks,
which is where we should have
been 45 minutes ago.
You see our problem here is
that we would like to talk
about martingales a little bit
in this course because
martingales are extremely
important things.
You can prove all sorts
of things from them.
An enormous amount of modern
research in the field uses
martingales, and you can do a
great deal with martingales
without knowing anything
about measure theory.
And almost all the books that
talk about martingales use
measure theory, and therefore,
require you to take a couple
of extra terms of math courses
before you can understand
what's going on.
So it's important to be able to
say something about them,
in this course, so
you have enough--
so you know when you
have to learn more
about them at least.
So I want to get to that point,
which is why I've been
speeding up a little bit from
what I would like to do.
If you noticed, if you've been
reading the notes, I have
skipped the [INAUDIBLE]
equations.
I have skipped semi-Markov
processes.
We're not going to
deal with them.
The [INAUDIBLE]
equations are quite important.
You use them quite a bit.
They play the same role for
Markov processes that all the
business with eigenvalues
we went through
play with Markov chains.
The trouble is we don't
have time to do it.
And the other trouble is all the
time that we would spend
understanding that would be
time understanding linear
systems of differential
equations.
And if you study that in math
and you have a good feel for
it, fine, you can read the
section and notes.
If you're not familiar with
that, then you have to learn
something about it.
It's not something we should
waste our time on because it's
not something we will use at any
other time in this course.
OK, so we want to get
onto random walks.
A random walk is, in fact, a
very simple kind of animal.
Let x sub i, i greater than or
equal to 1, be a sequence of
independent identically
distributed random variables.
And let s sub n be x1 plus x2
plus x sub n for n greater
than or equal to 1.
Is this something that we
spent a 1/4 of the term
talking about, or 1/2 the term
talking about, or 3/4 of the
term talking about?
I don't know, but we've
certainly spent an awful lot
of time talking about the sums
of iid random variables.
What is different here is that
instead of being interested in
these random variables s sub n,
what we're interested in is
this process of the s sub n's.
I mean, we're interested in
looking at the whole sequence
of them, and saying
things about that.
What we would like to
be able to do is say
questions of this sort.
You pick some alpha bigger
than 0, doesn't
matter what it is, 1.
What's the probability that s
sub n is greater than or equal
to alpha for at least one in
greater than or equal to 0?
So we're not asking, what's the
probability that s sub 10
is bigger than alpha.
We're asking, if we look at this
sequence, s1, s2, s3, s4,
what's the probability
that any one of
those terms cross alpha?
In other words, when we look
at the entire sample path,
does the entire sample path lie
below alpha or does the
sample path, at some point,
cross alpha, then perhaps,
come back down again or continue
to go up or do
whatever it wants to do.
What the question is, does it
cross it at least once?
The questions connected with
that are, if it does cross the
threshold, when does it
cross the threshold?
That's important.
If it crosses the threshold,
what's the overshoot with
which it crosses
the threshold?
Does it go shooting way
above the threshold
when it crosses it?
If you have one of these random
variables that has very
long tails, then it's very
likely that when you cross the
threshold, you've crossed a
threshold because of some
sample value which
is humongous.
And therefore, you typically
are going way above the
threshold when you cross it.
That makes the study of random
walks very much more
complicated than it would
be otherwise.
These overshoot problems are
extremely difficult, extremely
tedious, and unfortunately, very
often, very important.
So that's a bad combination, to
be tedious and important.
You would rather avoid
things like that.
Next one is given two thresholds
for a given alpha
bigger than 0, and a given
beta less than 0--
here we are, starting
out at 0.
We have a threshold up here
and a threshold down here.
And we want to know what's the
probability that we ever cross
one of the two thresholds.
That, I hope, you can
answer right away.
Can you?
s sub n, after a long
period of time, is
going to look Gaussian.
It's going to look Gaussian
with a standard deviation,
which is growing gradually.
And as a standard deviation
grows gradually, and we have
these two finite limits,
eventually, we're going to
cross one of those thresholds.
So the question is not do you
cross one of the thresholds?
The question is, which threshold
do you cross?
What's the probability of
crossing each of them?
At what end do you cross
the one that you cross?
And what's the overshoot
when you cross it?
So those are the questions
there.
These threshold crossing
problems are important.
They're important in almost
everything that you use
stochastic processes for.
They're familiar to me for
studying errors in digital
communications systems because
that's sort of the basis of
all of that study.
They're important in studying
the overflowing queues.
Anytime you build a queue, I
mean, what are you building?
You're building a waiting room
for customers, and you're
building a service facility.
And one of the first questions
is, how big do I have to make
the waiting room?
How much storage do I need,
is the question.
So you really want to be able to
answer the question, what's
the probability that the queue
will ever overflow the queue?
That's a threshold problem.
In hypothesis testing, when you
want to find out which of
two hypotheses is true,
this is important.
When you want to look at, what's
often a more important
question, is you test for one
or two hypotheses, and if
you're smart, and if you can
do it, you keep the test
running until you're pretty
sure that you
have the right answer.
If you've got the right answer
right away, then you can stop,
and save time from there on.
If you have to go for a long
time before you get the
answer, then you go
for a long time
before you get the answer.
That's called sequential
hypothesis
testing, and that's important.
There are these questions or
ruin and other catastrophes,
which, as you've observed in
this paper over the last few
years, most people don't know
how to deal with them.
If they do know how to deal
with them, they're too
affected by short term profits
and things like that that do
what they should do.
But part of the trouble is
people don't know how to deal
with those problems.
And therefore, if you're
trying to maximize your
profits and you can say, I've
talked to 10 experts, they've
told me five different things.
It gives you a perfectly good
excuse for maximizing your
profits rather than doing
something reasonably sensible
or reasonably safe.
So these are important
problems that
we're dealing with.
I'm going to start with a brief
discussion of three
simple cases.
First one is called simple
random walks.
The next one is called integer
random walks, and the third
one is called renewal
processes.
These random walks we're talking
about sound like very
simple minded things, but if
you think about it for a
minute, all of these renewal
processes we've spent all this
time studying and struggling
with, are just a special case
of random walks.
I mean, a renewal process has
non-negative random variables.
We're adding up those
non-negative random variables
to see what's going on.
So a renewal process is just
dealing with sums of iid
non-negative random variables,
where this is dealing with a
case where the random variables
can be either
positive or negative.
OK, so we're going to start with
a little bit about them.
A random walk is called simple
if the underlying random
variable xn n is the simplest
random random variable of all.
Mainly, it's binary.
The probability that it's 1,
that it's equal to 1, and the
probability is minus
1 is equal to q.
You could make it just 0 or 1,
namely, make it Bernoulli, but
that makes it too special.
I mean, since we've been
studying renewal processes,
where all these random variables
are non-negative,
let's take the plunge and study
the simplest case of
random variables, which can be
either positive or negative.
The simplest case is this binary
case, where the random
variables can be 1 or minus 1.
That's what a simple
random walk is.
OK, it's just a scaling
variation on our Bernoulli
process though.
The probability that xi
is equal to 1 for m
out of the n trials.
Mainly, you're going to flip
this coin x sub i, heads is 1,
tails is minus 1.
The probability that you get
heads for m out of the n
trials is n factorial
over m factorial
times n minus m factorial.
Number of combinations of n
things taken m at a time times
p to the m times 1 minus
p to the n minus m.
We've known that forever.
You probably knew
in high school.
You relearned it when you were
taking elementary probability.
We've talked about it
in this course.
We can also view this
as a Markov chain.
You start off in state
0 with probability p.
You go to state 1 with
probability 1 minus p.
You go to state minus 1.
On the second trial, you either
go to state 2 or to 1,
2 or to 0, or to minus
2, and so forth.
That's just another way of
analyzing the same simple
random walk.
Just like in the Stop When
You're Ahead game that we
talked about in class, the
probability that we ever cross
a threshold at k equal to p
over 1 minus p to the k.
Let me remind you of why this
is true, remind you of
something else.
I want to find the probability
that any s sub n is greater
than or equal to k, so I
need this union here.
Many people write that as
a maximum over n as the
probability that the maximum
over the s sub n's is greater
than or equal to k.
Other people write it as the
probability that the supremum
of this sum is greater
than or equal to k.
Why do I like to use the union,
other than the fact
that I like set theory
more than algebra?
Anybody know what some simple
reasons for that are?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It might not be
the max [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: You were just trying
to decide whether it crosses--
the sum-- that k right now,
whether it-- the maximum
implied that was as high
as it [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Not necessarily,
no.
I mean, I might not be able
to find the maximum.
If I'm not dealing with a simple
random walk, and I look
at the sequence S1, S2, S3,
S4, and I ask what's the
maximum of that sequence, the
maximum might not exist.
The supremum always exists if
you include infinity as a
possible value for it.
But the supremum is not
very nice either.
Because suppose I had a random
walk where it was possible for
the random variables to take on
arbitrarily small values.
And suppose I had a sequence
which went crawling up towards
1, as n increases, it keeps
climbing up towards 1, but it
never quite gets there.
What's the supremum of
that set of numbers?
1.
So the supremum is greater
than or equal to 1.
But that's not what
I'm interested in.
I'm interested in the
question, what's the
probability that any one of
these random variables is
greater than or equal to 1?
So that's the straightforward
way to write it.
Now does anybody care about
these minor differences of a
maximum or a supremum
or what have you?
No.
The only reason you care about
it is when you write a
maximum, after you become a
little bit careful with your
mathematics, you say,
is that a maximum?
Or is it a supremum?
So you write it as a supremum
and then you go through the
argument I just went through.
And the point is, you're not
interested in that at all.
All you're interested in
is do you cross the
threshold or don't you?
And this is the, natural
way to write it.
OK.
Now the next thing is, how do
we get this formula here?
Well, if we're going to cross a
threshold at k, and k is an
integer, there's not going
to be any overshoot.
We're either going to get there
and hit it, and then we
might go on beyond there.
We'll either hit it
on [INAUDIBLE]
or we won't hit it.
Now if we're going to hit it
at [INAUDIBLE], how are we
going to do that?
Well we have to hit
1 at some point.
Because you can only move up
or down by one at a time.
So you're going to have to
hit 1 at some point.
Given that you've hit 1, you
have to go on and hit 2 at
some point.
Given that you've hit 2, you
have to move up and hit 3 at
some point.
Those events are independent
of each other.
So the probability that you
ever get to k is the
probability that you can
stop when you're ahead.
Namely, it's the probability
that you go from 0 to 1 up to
the k-th power.
So I'm saying that p over 1
minus p is the probability you
ever move from state
0 up to state 1.
And when we were looking at Stop
When You're Ahead, it was
exactly this game here.
We moved up with probability
p, down with probability q.
We were looking at the
probability we'd ever be ahead
in this gambling game where we
kept betting money, and we
always had an infinite
capital.
So we could keep on
betting forever.
And we stopped as soon
as we hit 1.
So it's exactly this
question here.
The way we solved it at that
point was to write an
equation for it.
On the first step, you either
move up, and you're there.
Or you move down.
And if you move down, you
have to move up twice.
So the probability you ever
get from here to here is p
plus q times the probability
you get from here squared.
You solve that quadratic
equation.
You might remember solving
that before.
And that's where you get
to p over 1 minus p.
OK, so that's not terribly
important.
What is important is that this
is the only problem in random
walks I know which has
a trivial solution.
Most problems have a harder
solution than that.
But there is at least one
problem which is easy.
Now for those of you worried
about a final exam, final
exams have to find problems
which are easy.
So that tells you something.
I mean, we have to take the easy
results in this course,
and we have to use
them in someway.
And since I'm telling
you that, I probably
will include it, so--
OK.
Integer random walks.
That's the next kind of random
walk to talk about.
x is an integer random
variable.
So similarly, s sub n is an
integer random variable.
So when we're moving up, we
move up in integer values,
which makes things a
little bit easier.
This means, again, that we can
model this as a Markov chain.
In the Markov chain, we start
at 0, we move up whatever
number of values x sub n can
have, or we move down whatever
number of values it can have.
And then from there, we
keep moving again.
So it's this Markov chain with
a very regular structure,
where for each state, the set
of various states of up
transition and set of down
transitions are all the same
for all the states.
So that's a simple Markov
chain to deal with.
OK, and then we said that
renewal processes are special
cases of random walks where x is
a positive random variable.
When you're sketching sample
paths, the axes are usually
reversed from random processes
to random walks.
I'm just pointing this out
because every time you try to
go from a random walk to a
two-way renewal process, you
will be happily writing
equations and drawing pictures
of what you're doing.
And you will suddenly come up
against this problem, which is
that whenever you draw a figure
for a renewal process,
you draw it this way.
OK?
In other words, what you're
looking at is the time at
which the n-th arrival occurs.
Time is going this way.
The time at which the first
arrival occurs is S1.
The time at which the second
arrival occurs is
S2, S3, and so forth.
These intervals here--
x1, x2, x3, x4, x5,
and so forth--
whenever you're dealing with
a random walk, what you're
interested in directly
these s's and x's.
And you always draw it
the opposite way
with the axes reversed.
And what's confusing to you at
first is that when you see
this picture, it doesn't look
like this picture at all.
These two pictures
are identical
with the axes reversed.
One is the way you draw
renewal processes.
The other is the way you
draw random walks--
which also suggests that
sometimes when you're dealing
with random walks, you want
to draw a picture like the
picture you draw for renewal
processes and vice versa.
So the two are very
closely related.
OK, so I want to do a little bit
about the queuing delay in
a G/G/1 queue.
We've talked about G/G/1 queues
a little bit in terms
of Little's Theorem and
various other things.
And there's one very simple
thing about G/G/1 queues that
follows from looking
at random walks.
And there's a nice part of the
problem you can solve dealing
with random walks.
Let's let x sub i be the IID
random variables, which are
inter-arrival intervals
for the G/G/1 queue.
Here's the first inter-arrival
interval.
Here's the second.
Here's the third.
Here's the fourth up
here, and so forth.
The departure occurs--
there's an inherent arrival that
we visualize at time 0.
y 0 is a service time that
that arrival requires.
y1 is the service time that this
first arrival requires.
y2 is the service time
of the third arrival.
These service times are all
independent of each other.
We've looked at this
picture before.
What we haven't done is
to draw the obvious
conclusion from it.
If you try to talk about what
is the waiting time in queue
of the n-th customer, how can
we draw that in a figure?
Well here it is in
this figure.
The 0-th customer has no waiting
time at all, because
there's nothing in the queue.
It goes directly into
the server.
I'm just talking about queueing
time, not system time.
So 0 goes directly into the
server, takes some long
service time, ends here.
The next arrival occurs at
this time here after this
inter-arrival time.
And what's it have to do?
It has to wait until this
customer finishes.
And then it has to wait for its
own service time before it
gets out of the system.
The next customer comes in x2
units of time after the first
customer comes in.
So it comes in here.
It has to wait in queue until
after the first customer gets
finished, and so forth.
Now look at the time from the
arrival of the second customer
until the second customer
goes into service.
What is that?
It can be written in
two different ways.
And this is the observation
that makes it possible to
analyze G/G/1 queues.
The inter-arrival time of the
second customer plus the
queueing time of the second
customer is equal to the
queuing time of the first
customer plus the service time
of the first customer.
OK?
This time is equal
to that time.
Put little ovals around them
so you can spot it.
So in general, if the arrival n
is queued, then xn plus wn,
the inter-arrival time for the
n-th customer plus its waiting
time in queue is equal to the
service time of the previous
customer plus the waiting
time of the
previous customer in queue.
If arrival n sees an empty
queue, then wn equals 0.
OK?
This is easy.
If you didn't draw
this picture, it
would be very hard.
If you tried to do this
by algebra, you
would never get done.
But when you draw a picture,
there's nothing to it.
OK, so that says w sub n is
equal to y sub n minus 1 minus
xn plus w sub n minus 1 if w sub
n minus 1 plus yn minus 1
is greater than or equal
to xn, namely, if xn
gets queued at all.
And otherwise, w sub
n is equal to 0.
In other words, if the n-th
customer enters a queue which
is empty, it doesn't wait
in queue at all.
It goes right into service if
that condition is satisfied.
So we can write this whole thing
as w sub n is equal to
the maximum of w sub n minus 1
plus yn minus 1 minus xn or 0.
Namely, what's happening is that
the amount of time that
each customer has to wait in the
queue, not in the system--
waiting time in the queue is
either this quantity here
that's related to the waiting
time of the previous customer
added to the service time of
the previous customer minus
the n arrival time of
the customer before.
If you define u sub n as y sub
n minus 1 minus plus xn--
y sub n minus 1 minus xn--
namely, the service time of
the n minus first customer
minus the inter-arrival time for
the n-th customer, this is
independent over n.
So this is a IID random
variable.
Each of the arrivals
x sub n are IID.
Each of the departures
and each of the
service times are IID.
Arrivals and services are
independent of each other.
So this u sub n random variable
is a sequence of IID
random variables.
And what this is saying then,
is that w sub n is equal to
the maximum of w sub n
minus 1 plus un or 0.
If for the time being,
ignore that maximum.
I mean, suppose the queue
is very, very long.
The queue is very, very long.
You don't have 0.
Everybody has some
service time.
This would be a random walk
then. w sub n, the waiting
time for the n-th customer, is
equal to the waiting time of
the n minus first customer
plus u sub n.
u sub n is playing the role of
the inter-arrival in the
random walk.
That's the x's that we had
in the random walk.
w sub n minus 1 is the sum.
w sub n is equal to the previous
sum plus the new
random variable coming in.
So without the maximum, this
is just a random walk.
The w sub n's are the random
walk based on these peculiar
random variables u sub i, which
are the peculiar random
variables of service times minus
inter-arrival times.
OK.
With the max, this says w sub
n is like a random walk.
What does it do?
It keeps going up for a while
you have a queue.
Then it might start dropping.
But it can't go negative.
Whenever it gets down to 0, it
gets down below 0, the next
time you start at 0 again.
And you start going again.
The next time it goes
negative, you get
bumped up to 0 again.
It's like a naughty kid who
goes through all sorts of
problems, but as soon as he goes
negative, somebody picks
him up and starts him
back up again.
So it's a--
well, it's a different
kind of process.
But anyway, it's like a random
walk, except it has this
peculiar characteristic that
any time it crosses the 0
threshold, it gets bumped back
up, and you start over again.
So you have these segments
which make it a renewal
process also.
You have renewals whenever
you get to 0 and
you start over again.
And we'll talk about how those
processes work later.
The text has another way of
looking at it, where you look
at this random walk going
backwards in time rather than
forward in time.
But we don't want to spend
a lot of time on that.
We just want to see this does
have something to do with
random walks.
I want to spend some real time
studying detection and
decisions and hypothesis
testing, because each one of
these things are very important
in a number of
different fields.
If you study radar or any kind
of military problem, detection
is very important.
You want to see whether
something has happened or not.
And often you have to see
whether it's happened in the
presence of a great deal
of noise or something.
So you're not sure of whether
it's happened or not.
So you make many observations to
see whether it's happened.
And then you try to make a
decision on the basis of all
of those things.
Decisions--
that's what control people
think about all the time.
Control freaks always want
to make decisions.
They don't want you
They want to make the decisions
themselves.
But that's part of what
studying random
processes is all about.
How do you make sensible
decisions?
You generally--
when you make a decision, you
make it with some uncertainty
connected to it.
I mean, people respond to this
by pretending there isn't any
uncertainty.
They pretend when they
made a decision that
they must be right.
But actually, they
could be wrong.
And sensible people face the
fact that they might be wrong.
And therefore, they try to
analyze what's the probability
of being wrong, what's the
probability of being right,
and all of these things.
Hypothesis testing--
all scientists deal with this.
There are competing theories
in some field, and in these
competing theories, you want to
find out which is the right
hypothesis.
So you do a lot of tests.
And after all those tests, you
try to decide which hypothesis
you believe in.
Why is it important
to make a choice?
Well it's important to make a
choice in all sorts of reasons
and all sorts of areas.
Even in a scientific
area, I mean-- the
field has to move somehow.
If the field has all sorts
of open questions and if
everybody says, well, there
might be quantum theory, or
there might not be
quantum theory.
It might all be wrong.
It might all be right.
I don't know.
I mean there's noise
in the system,
we can't tell anything.
So all they're dealing with is
a set of very complicated
probabilities.
Instead of that, people
do make decisions.
They say, let's proceed on the
basis of what they think is
the best course of action.
You're voting for a candidate
for public office.
Well you can say,
I don't care.
But you can't vote for both.
You have to choose
one or the other.
And you have to make
a decision,
what's the best choice?
So these problems arise
everywhere.
And if you leave these problems
out of the study of
random processes, what
are you left with?
A purely academic exercise.
OK?
All you're doing is you're
establishing probabilities,
but you're not using them.
So this is sort of where the
rubber hits the road, when you
study decision making or
hypothesis testing or
detection, whichever one
you want to call it.
But you absolutely need to make
these hypothesis tests at
some point.
We're going to call them
hypothesis tests because the
language used there seems to
be easier to live with than
the language in other places.
Not that I like the way the
statisticians do these things.
Statisticians talk about errors
of the first kind and
errors of the second kind.
And I and everyone else I know
never knows what's the first
kind and what's the
second kind?
But they never talk about giving
names to these things.
It's always first kind and
seconds kind and so forth.
But we won't bother ourselves
about that.
What we're going to do is we'll
consider only problems
where you have two possible
decisions.
So it's a binary decision
problem, binary hypothesis
testing problem.
We're going to consider a
sample space which has a
random variable called
h in it.
The random variable h can have
two possible values, 0 or 1.
And you're going to have the
multiple observations that
you're going to make, Y1, Y2,
Y3, Y4, up to y sub n, say.
To make the problem easy and
to make it correspond to
random walks, we're going to
assume that the observations
are IID conditional on h equals
0, and they're also ID
conditional on h equals 1.
If you're used to studying noise
problems, a nice example
of this is you send one of two
binary values over some
communication channel.
There's additive noise
added to it.
At the receiver, what you see
is what you sent plus some
additive noise.
You try to figure out from that
sum of signal plus noise
was a 0 sent, or was a 1 sent?
And you don't know which
was sent, and you
have to take a guess.
And usually if the noise is not
too big, you can make a
very good guess, so you don't
make many errors.
This is exactly the
problem that we're
concerned with here.
If you have multiple
observations, you can think of
sending that same binary
digit n times.
And then on the basis of all
of those observations, see
what you want to guess.
I mean scientific
experiments--
does a scientific theory ever
get resolved by one
experiment?
I mean sometimes you read in
textbooks that it does.
But it never does.
Somebody does an experiment.
They come up with
some conclusion.
And immediately 10 other groups
around the world are
all doing the same experiment
to validate it or
not validate it.
Maybe they don't all publish
papers about it.
But pretty soon, that experiment
is done so many
times with so many variations
on it that you can think of
having multiple observations
of the same thing.
OK.
So when we got all done with it,
we're going to assume that
the observations will have
probability density functions.
They're analog and the
hypothesis is binary.
Doesn't make any difference, you
can have observations that
are discrete also.
It's just whether you want to
use probability mass functions
or probability density
functions.
It looks a little bit easier
to do it this way.
So the probability density of
having n observations given
that the hypothesis l is
the correct one is
this product here.
And that's true for both l
equals 1 and l equals 0.
Let me go just a little
bit further.
Baye's law then says that the
probability that h is equal to
the hypothesis l is equal to the
a priori probability that
the alt hypothesis is correct
times this density divided by
the sum of the two densities.
Nothing fancy here at all.
If you compare these
two probabilities--
probability that 0 is a correct
hypothesis with the
probability that 1 is the
correct hypothesis--
you take the ratio of these.
What you get this p0 over p1
times this density divided by
that density.
Well this was thought of well
over 100 years ago, probably
150 years ago.
People fought about it terribly,
terrible fights
about this.
One of the worst fights in
science that's ever happened.
Then we had Bayesian
statisticians and non-Bayesian
statisticians.
And you know, these people were
all perfectly willing to
talk about conditional
probabilities so long as they
were looking forward in time.
When they started looking
backward in time, namely
looking at these conditional
probabilities going backwards,
and saying, we have hypotheses
in our model.
These have probabilities.
We will talk about these
probabilities
of everything involved.
We have a complete probabilistic
model.
We will talk about-- in this
probabilistic model, when you
get a certain observation,
what's the probability the one
hypothesis is correct?
What's the probability the other
People suddenly lost everything
they'd learned
about probability, and said
this can't be right.
So there were enormous
fights about it.
Anyway, I wanted to
get to that point.
Think about that.
Next time we're going to
start out and do a
little bit with this.
And suddenly a random walk
is going to emerge.
So we will do that next time.